es ist tag drei unserer forderung nach
der freedom suite die diskussion um die
lockerung der korona maßnahmen sie zieht
seit unserem appell am montag wirklich
weite kreise und auch heute sagen noch
einmal es reicht gebt uns unser normales
leben zurück
ja unser bild live chef claus strunz hat
dazu deutliche worte gefunden hier bei
uns hat er bei freedom weg auch ein
nahezu romantisches datum
ich passe mich jetzt was kann ich meine
art ist mal der agenda der politik an
nächste woche ist eine mpk angekündigt
für den 16 wenn ich richtig sie beginnt
die woche mit dem valentinstag also
einem großen tag der liebe dann lasst
uns doch die nächste woche zur freiheit
woche machen in deutschland
also heute feiert schweden seinen
freedom day die inzidenz dort liegt über
2000 die hospitalisierung rate sie
steigt doch schweden schafft jetzt auch
die letzten maßnahmen ab
veranstaltungen können ohne teilnehmer
grenze und im nachweis stattfinden
restaurants können so lange offen
bleiben wie sie wollen abstandsregel im
handel werden abgeschafft die masken
pflicht in bus und bahn zu stoßzeiten
fällt dabei ist schweden schon jetzt
freier als deutschland und viele andere
länder denn schweden war noch keinen
einzigen tag im lock down und wurde
dafür heftig kritisiert wir erinnern uns
karl lauterbach und markus söder
erklärten schwedens strategie für
gescheitert weil das land in der ersten
ko- novelle höhere todeszahlen hatte als
wir aber was sagen die schwedischen
bürger freuen sie sich über den freedom
day und bereuen sie ist dass ihre
regierung nie den lockdown verhängt
hatte fragen die uns unser meinungs-
schiffe philippiak offen beantworten
kann denn der ist jetzt live vor ort er
ist in schweden erste frage an dich wie
fühlt sich das an dieses ganz andere
lebens erlebt
ja hallo thomas hallo sandra es ist
wirklich wie ein besuch auf einem
anderen planeten ich bin gestern in
stockholm angekommen habe mich in den
zug gesetzt in die innenstadt und habe
erstmal einen älteren herren da keine
maske trug gefragt sagen sie gibt es
hier eigentlich masken pflicht im zug
er wusste das nicht hat gesagt ich weiß
es nicht und hat weiter biathlon
geschaut und dieses gefühl ist hier
wirklich dominant man merkt corona nicht
wirklich man geht ins café und wird
nicht gefragt ob man geimpft oder
genesen ist also heute ist freedom day
heute sind die letzten maßnahmen
gefallen aber auch gestern schon war
schweden war stockholm deutlich freier
als wir die menschen haben sich
innerlich glaube ich schon längst
verabschiedet von diesen dauerhaften
pandemie zustand und heute nun auch
offiziell seit beginn der pandemie macht
es schweden anders als viele andere
länder vor allem anders auch als wir
hier in deutschland was können wir uns
von den schweden abgucken
ich glaube wir können uns von den
schweden abgucken dass man wirklich mit
ruhe und gesunde menschenverstand
manchmal regieren sollte und nicht nur
mit angst und panik ich habe hier mit
vielen schweden gesprochen und die sagen
dinge die eigentlich selbstverständlich
sein sollten auch in deutschland mehr
hat gestern eine junge frau gesagt ich
fand es gut dass unsere regierung uns
nichts aufgezwungen hat sondern dass sie
uns immer wieder dinge empfohlen hat und
an die haben wir uns auch gehalten wenn
wir wollten ich finde das eine sehr
vernünftige haltung denn wenn man sich
anschaut wenn man sich die zahlen
anschaut dann ist schweden eben nicht
gescheitert wie beispielsweise karl
lauterbach das sehr schnell erklärt hat
sondern die todeszahlen pro einwohner
sind in schweden nur minimal höher als
in deutschland der wirtschaftliche
schaden ist in schweden deutlich
geringer und auch die ganzen
nebenwirkungen waren natürlich viel viel
weniger schweden hat beispielsweise
seine grundschule nie geschlossen das
heißt kinder konnten ganz normal
miteinander lernen miteinander spielen
und mussten nicht zu hause sein wurden
nicht zu hause eingesperrt und natürlich
ist es auch die gesellschaftliche
spaltung die es in deutschland leidet
gibt immer mehr gibt und in schweden die
es einfach nie gab weil menschen hier
nie ausgegrenzt wurden weil sie
beispielsweise nicht geimpft waren
gefragt ein niemand nach dem
impfnachweis wenn man ins café oder ins
restaurant geht und ich glaube dass es
sehr viel wert die schwedische
gesellschaft ist glaube ich insgesamt
besser durch die korona krise durch
gekommen als wir philipp sie also heute
noch ganz kurz gehst du heute noch
feiern wir beneiden mich etwas
ich gehe heute abend auf jeden fall
einige alkoholische getränke trinken ob
es feiern wird schauen wir mal aber es
ist ein unglaubliches gefühl einfach
hier zu sein ehrlich gesagt auch schon
vor dem freedom day weil es gibt hier
keinen alarm zustand es gibt hier keinen
pandemie zustand man merkt das ist ein
freies land das hat sich innerlich
längst von der partie verabschiedet und
ja darauf werde ich heute abend
garantiert ein trinken genießen
live aus schweden wo heute der freedom
day gefeiert wird vielen dank für diese
eindrücke